the underdog belong shot the dark horse
sometimes you just can't help but cheer
for the David over the cs Goliath I'm
looking at you big
that's why this week on best of we're
taking a look at those David's of the
csgo world guys these are players who
defied our expectations of them who
stepped up a weight class to show they
can go toe-to-toe with the best teams
and players in the world
this dinged-up aerial does finish him
off and it's just all ooh all alone
thirty seconds in a one on four he's got
to find simple first that he does sees
the shoulder right off the bat drops
down tries to catch someone off-guard
doesn't happen Ino Zeus's in the open
though he needed that flick he needs to
get the follow up and he does he's got a
fourth now we can get the bomb planted
in all ooh it's his turn to go nuts
final um v1 this is incredible for
Marlow he's got the Molotov as well this
could just buy time but Electrike has
been good so far this game do not ride
him out all who now prepares himself 36
HP the fight begins four kills the
Molotov goes in and there it is
incredible work from all the ACE when
they needed the most that'll allow a
plant for Smith's but he's still in one
versus two on top the site jumping oh my
god good night Smith's as well working
in tandem
he made a nice option that could have
very easily been missed good stuff 3k
really feeling it at the moment that
leads to be all either rotator who gotta
kill the drop earlier in the round to
have to come into one on three not
necessarily spotted but doesn't got the
Bob so bombs far away take hold from
watts ago will they make it for a very
nice and it can't be any room for
mistakes they're getting caught up in
the moment hit only back to me buddy
allowing the plot to go to Vegas
quadrant so they can take this two
versus one shadow though does have a
real opportunity here coastal quick
reload just about has time for that
as in comes both of lav focus on de how
does he get that one one versus two
around away from $25,000 Laney can open
up trying to see me here you get it
almost takes down Ethan and their full
offer electronic long range free and
maybe a bit too long they are just
running in one at a time na'vi trying to
see if they can be the first to maybe
make this happen in circus to finally
cut it off of it
three good kills of the round the quad
kill for him impact and now soos the
last one left concert' get that piece I
feel like that would be consolation
prize at this point looking for it and
he's gonna be able to pick it up just to
see that defeated Gopi can still win
this one he's got the UMP now man this
should be absolutely absurd he's gonna
Dinkin he has the advantage at the
incursians position
[Applause]
no utility these tunnels see find
anything as bombsight
yeah but a very awkward angle to watch
those tolls jks muster peak in this
closet area nose ball up there now and
FNX is pushing up through these tunnels
balling dates that are out the window
not able to find one FJ KS gets it but
he's gonna get his fourth flip around
don't be to kill so pop and tasty and
con help about 50 seconds final round
has to go for this one with the air
already in blinded not spotted
I get the cross as well smoothie is
gonna know exactly where he is because
the bullet toffler's out ticket in fact
you want me to be touched by that which
means he can peek by copy he's ready for
that angle picks out the palm plants as
well that won't fake body and he's got
time to work with 31 seconds thought he
knows that note he doesn't have to
commit so why should he bother peeking
let him have the plant play this as a
true one-on-one really spotted him for
treating smoke you know he's on the wall
probably section doesn't have to eat the
Manteno it's just got a train and Ethan
there's gonna be going down taco doing
such a good job with that flank hugely
important obviously otherwise we're the
south of taps gonna be one more kill oh
my god he gets the headshots pimp in the
round
you still owe it with we go almost a
sucker but not quite it all falls under
JPS in the back to the side the open
hand and a1 b2 existed rain left to try
and find which goes out from range aks
knows where he is
right it's part of the back we've got a
gold as well he's a couple Thank You Man
challenge again picture from Jake yet
this to be N 1 b1 Molotov and flashbang
deployed take it by the ak-47 this could
be the frag and he's done it
renegades out going to the playoffs next
big story
goes through and find simple chances he
actually shuts down electronic the next
is full of sex that he shuts up Susan is
damn fine in a few fine aces chrome ins
yesterday's up there taps ins in the
pistol today this I think would top them
all given the circumstances given if we
were about to go to a tie game they were
in a triple eco situation and he's got
all five murders Pro the huge advantage
there's a follow up flight coming
actually so we're yes but he gets taken
down never saw it coming now the leaner
and Jim K left trying to see if they can
just crush versus Pro here to onto I'm
only just down this Jim cover the one
shot and now pasture in the corner all
alone
getting shot up from two different
angles and he gets dropped by jim Kerr
and that's it rotating up who is the
star of the previous map over on trade
this time he's gonna go barreling
through he's able to find that first
good okay J KS 1 B 1 vs. exist
Tom yet to go down 15 seconds left on
the clock J KS just playing with his
food he's gonna go through when he wins
it out he gets the 1 B 3 I was a lovely
if he doesn't want to get caught out
against potential numbers game that's
said in confidence Vega squadron will
set that for fans Awards the a sign that
Bush is coming in from face and
basically walk down give you some kills
though but the love is being spread from
Vega squadron a pop flash crossfire set
to watch just gets obliterated knows
that actually opens up quite a bit
because never so limited on how he could
peek get Malta three quick kills as he
snaps back to get MSL as well and I
would say this pistol goes to a of chief
stats conduct versus four ball planted
[Music]
I get what is that I'm going back
towards the a-site the full rotation is
here but rate is almost already on the
flank this big this might force the hand
of cloud nine hours they having to drop
the player three there though for space
soldiers to look to defeat this push
there is the peak there's the flashbang
very important how come centaurs gets
nothing
down to pass picks brush off the air now
another one from past what else can you
all why goodness pass for from him
absolutely unbelievable there from him
oh my god the ACE to take the match is
with us house controls got paper cop the
aspen tree frack fault blows naka no
those from our goats Moyer comes back up
da laufen Z gets wounded behind we have
exit nobody posits you're passed out oh
god bad lap of tides booyah head yep
Frankie's gonna flash through it that's
gonna catch the double flash double
blind blinky it doesn't peak on it ooh
Molotov just so much damage though
because the blind they're in the flames
and they're in the grave taps it with
two food has to be forced back off as
another smollett on plants directly in
front of city area if you will good push
from Goffe to capitalize back-up plan is
be phelps his opening it cold already
has got me down but he's got a run
quickly in this has to be health captain
says no it's on the coal than a one
versus three
surely no he's got a gun thankfully
because taps in' has gone by the smoke
jumps up no noise jumps up no feet
spotted just good up these cold
miss bombs been taking for a while again
luminosity such a desperate situation
attacker not spotted a teemo goes for
the lay pete taco gets the shot no it's
fallen over his shoulder but now it's
just down to taco won't fan he's gonna
clutch it out yeah three games at
momentum but
to battle it and the traits will be in
waterfalls a very tight spot all onto a
train gets out of there as well
and there is no way to pursue him right
now tizian left in the 201 he's got an
m4 picked up Calvin
he's got the hole you know guys players
get injured it happens and when they do
there is a roster hole to fill now the
person who substitutes is usually not
the one with the entire team on their
back and yet it happens this next
section highlights those coaches and
subs who stepped up up for their team
when they really needed it I'm looking
at you chrome and Chrome and snaps back
with speed as well to pull it off the
stand stands up and he might make big
sit the hell down because tizian tries
to get to the ball a quick tap Romans
not responded his ice on this but he's
not moving either respect he could give
himself up this hinted check in chrome
and bolts the angle of plays this to
perfection
no can't map and oh no it's too far card
I think Romans pulled off the impossible
time that is
oh wait the basics once again go towards
be smoking front of the entrance and see
if it works out once more if it goes on
it he's flying now with this dwb this
sonic gets three kills to close it
device with the other two fine stop Zeus
oh good shot by hip to kill disgusting
oh he's gonna get a third as well starix
now goes for the peak on the face after
the flash not a kill but these do damage
telling the haze you think with that
many shots he already got one but now he
does he's got two is they got up close
makes up for any spades as he finds a
third up to the new flash go you nothing
to open cross not sluice all nothing you
grind up update doesn't pertain to my
toilet alone you don't got to figure out
laughing got cut quick Klaus you spray
Quadra kill
and now my money is running low it's
break no matter who wins this game she
starts in response and that's something
that also you know device in watching
all those demos he couldn't be very
aware all these spots but Fox finds a
very fast headshot at such range and
here is the stylist they want to meet
the split-pushing
but it will be folks and knocks them to
the vice can't respond with more than a
single frag leaving a completely clear
bomb site for the taking Dennis with the
Boost on the other side bit of a
crossfire he's actually got a track turn
sneaking in his coals here but he goes
down Dennis for the great Dunnigan just
like that
you know guys everybody has a rookie
season and even the most iconic of csgo
champions were once simply contenders
that's why this next section looks at
the csgo superstars of today before
their trophy cases were full so I wonder
if even eat a flash before this happens
the smoke comes out oh it might be
awkward timing he does quite a bit of
damage though three players go down and
one left and he steals it the 480 are
eighty card on their hold finally
response out of one the bump don't get
planted big job do you hear cold respond
so to stop evaluates you on - shall we
rust solo but this is winnable for cold
cold now trying to take his time himself
unaware as to where he's positioned at
so as he sneaks back out Roca is gonna
be just drawn the quarter doesn't bottom
takes out you know be looking for the
second kill he's gonna close it out
so electronic didn't have a terrible
first map but this is asking a lot yeah
okay that'll do 1v2 now with some time
to play and he actually get on this bomb
fairly quickly here he is gonna get the
drop another big headshot for him now
it's the 1v1 and con figures showing
himself but it's still favors electronic
perfectly done Mouse's by it's gonna be
torn away from the very very slippy by
Sunday oh my god shocked then isn't
gonna touch him just happened as deagle
is well nico is on fire angled shot
there on to pronate so now it's a 2-1
three all of mice are gonna get caught
maybe he'll races in spite of the
horrible start they're gonna be able to
find a way to bring it back here
JW [ __ ] and UT spawn and simple just
goes on the hunt against the kills 12 to
3 well guys that's all I got for you on
best of this week now if there's one
takeaway from this video that I want you
to have it's to keep following your
passions always persevere exercise your
potential and never forget your dreams
oh and subscribe to the score eSports
see you next week thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button